i'm taking steps tonight to make testing  more available more affordable and more  convenient  i'll use the defense production act to  increase production of rapid tests  including those that you can use at home  while that production is ramping up  my administration has worked with top  retailers like walmart amazon and  krogers  and tonight we're announcing that no  later than next week each of these  outlets will start to sell at home rapid  test kits  at cost  for the next three months  this immediate  price reduction  for at home test kits for up to 35  percent reduction  we'll also expand expand free testing  at 10 000 pharmacies around the country  and we'll commit we're committing 2  billion dollars  to purchase nearly 300 million rapid  tests for distribution to community  health centers  food banks  schools  so that every american no matter their  income  can access free and convenient tests